you guys listen and you listen good i
don't give a flying [ __ ] flip about the
marketing reports we are losing consumer
attention they are bored to show we've
done everything we can on that front the
hell you have zayn the hell you
have
what you've done are worldwide
exclusives fancy transitions expensive
pre-recorded presentations fake live
events live live events and some
dimcious narrative garbage that didn't
go anywhere melissa data the data is
clear the industry analytics point to
fragmented attention in every consumer
focused vector but one and that is the
countdowns those ridiculous 30-minute
celebrities soaked attention grab
couches before our company's actual
presentation actually starts actually
they are big dumb wasteful empty and
they work she's right i want to look of
course i'm [ __ ] right
so this year we're counting down
that's the focus the countdown it's all
about the calcium no holds barred
anything goes
all stops pulled out of where the [ __ ]
stops are that people keep pulling them
out of yeah okay sure but what are we
counting down to
what happens when we get to zero it
doesn't [ __ ] matter you can propose
to your mistress for all i care i just
want big number consumer eyeballs drying
out as they watch a marketing laden
countdown where we're drip feeding them
brand awareness and purchase intent
until they climax and their g fuel
soaked gamer chairs no not yet gross i'm
getting it though
so who do we have on deck to host this
thing i mean we need someone right
do a celebrity
can we get james van der beek team pacey
huh i'm just saying to the people a
giant [ __ ] robot with whoever the
[ __ ] we want inside of it hosting our
show inside of it hosting our show
i'm sorry what hold
we've designed developed and deployed a
wideband interlocal net modulated
telepresence experience through which a
virtual host can virtually host our
virtually hosted countdown broadcast
so what like a zoom call no no not like
a zoom margaret now
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
i noticed you stopped counting the
numbers
whatever is not a number my guy
let me see if we can get you some kind
of a break from the numerals match
my name's margaret shut up madge
does this
does this thing uh
i'm sorry
does this thing have access to the feeds
yes it has access to the feed all feeds
every the feeds on the planet heck even
deep into trans local space with a
little extra juice you could even
transmit all the way sure
can he
can he do trailers
yes
trailers number station feeds launch
codes replicants update satellite
destruct instructions suggestive
tick-tock dances the basics
it's also equipped with a tricordal
thermonuclear essential masses placement
cannon
hot stuff uh give me the button
okay yeah sure whatever
let's see you and i put the marketing
into the devolver digital marketing
countdown to marketing and give the fine
audience at home something
[Music]
a video game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hello
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
no we didn't make that massive monster
made it yeah people are going to be
obsessed when it drops
well no not just the videos
we're the publisher
we publish the games that's important
stuff you know it's basically the same
thing as making the games without all
the you know effort creativity time
energy that goes into making said game
i think of us as a humanitarian service
like fema or crocs you guys see the
numbers that sheep game or whatever did
us a duper mad spike wild stuff really
wild stuff
it tastes like baby food
have you guys seen the numbers i know
right no you don't know
what do you know i know the numbers keep
going like this i'm gonna buy a house
what's going on is it working on the
[ __ ] moon
pre-sales engagement but these numbers
are like nothing we've ever seen
well that's good though right too good
nina these numbers are like nothing
anyone has seen something's wrong we
need to tell hazel this needs to stop
whoa whoa whoa sport just corral up all
your little horses take a breath make
some sense what i'm saying is that it
doesn't make sense it can't make sense
according to the tracking we're just you
guys [ __ ] with the numbers
no one's [ __ ] with anything we just
rolled a [ __ ] hot trip what the holy
heck is going on with these numbers
what's at the end of 2001 with a
gigantic jupiter space baby and dave's
all shriveled up and computer's going
now it's like beep boop
that's a weirdly specific amount of time
i wonder if
huh
kind of hope to trade
so
so
no
[Music]
there's no comp in that that was an
accident holy but another engagement
spike the chat's going nut so our social
media ratings and marketing relevancy
are shooting through the roof somebody
tell me what the [ __ ] is going on moon
house a [ __ ] house on the moon what
if it's it's the yeah yeah that's great
what if it's the jack no yeah what if
it's the trailers
your big dumb robot uh do you think
[Music]
oh okay
yeah i was thinking something a little
more along like yeah
knew it let's
make sure
[Music]
so
[Music]
yeah another massive spike like big time
what do the numbers look like though
they just just keep going up it's
absolutely insane this isn't real this
can't be real it's like some kind of
no
no it can't be did you just say video
game singularity oh my god wait what are
we talking about right now
video game singularity is a hypothetical
moment of absolute corporate convergence
an event horizon into which
kaleidoscopically manifold fractionated
conglomerate interests are inescapably
pulled
and at a single point of infinite
density
compressed against the entropic
inevitability of like i don't know years
of inter-industry corporate mergers
acquisitions between developers
publishers platform holders and soulless
holding companies
everyone buying merging with and
acquiring everyone else until the only
[ __ ] thing left anymore is one giant
thick throbbing
ultraman omni company eating up
everything in its way
it can't be bargained with it can't be
reasoned with it doesn't feel pity or
remorse or fear and it absolutely will
not stop ever until everything is one
thing and that one thing is
everything and that thing is us
oh god love jesus christ so two moon
houses you're not getting insane imagine
all platforms all iconic characters all
methods of monetization
all heartballed up into one monopolistic
origin of interactive video
entertainment imagine streaming your
favorite prequel as a service on on your
virtual phone while you're sitting on a
toilet in a in a metaverse taco bell
while while you have sonic the hedgehog
in a committed non-monogamous
relationship with with that huge lady
from resident evil and they are they
could be playing apex sport zone on an
atari dream station 64. and it would all
be free to play or play the art
how did this happen
it's the mech
it's gotta be
it's the only thing powerful enough to
do it
[Music]
you guys
you guys follow the directions right
oh of course
[Music]
well
[Music]
once upon a time there was a plucky
squire named jot
jot roamed the land in search of
adventure
battling beasts
helping the helpless
and generally being very heroic
but then one day he discovered something
rather curious
a world he never knew existed
[Music]
i can't tell if it's just that these
games are amazing or if it's what the
[ __ ] happened to my shirt
what's going on
is this a singularity i just got sent a
review copy of metal gear cooking mama
mobile i don't even know what that means
do you even know what that means the the
industry's folding in on itself dude
what is called this car it slaps real
hard 10 out of 10. that's not the point
chief you'll just put in an offer to buy
valve
microsoft bought bethesda again
just for fun just what the ever shooting
[ __ ] fire have you [ __ ] done now oh
um uh plucky squire we just did the
plucky squire thing yeah it was legit
the sauce to my robot what have you done
to my goddamn robot and what's with your
shirt it's the singularity
what is the problem
the video game singularity
somehow this big dumb whatever the [ __ ]
is channeling egregious amounts of hype
and marketing power into a single point
and everything is converging on that
point right here so what is the problem
soon devolver digital ink will become
the sole arbiter of all video games and
everything that goes along with it
a lone single mega platform with total
an unstoppable absolute command over
everything
so what is the problem
[Music]
we don't know what we're doing
the devolver barely functions as a
marginally successful video game
publisher we can't be the
central ordinal nexus of all industry
why not
why
why are you getting this oh i get it
this is the uh
yeah
you can't
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
jesus annapurna interactive just merged
with mountain dew [ __ ] they're gonna
make a soft drink out of journey
it's not gonna stop
the hype is too great it's the county
we made a countdown with nothing at the
end just to get viewers and built a
machine we don't understand to do the
counting down we were so preoccupied
with whether or not we could we didn't
stop to think if we should
we can't stop counting it can't even
stop itself counting this machine
is a mechanized construct of of
stuff
that's
complicated it's off the rails and it's
just as stuck as we are so
no moon house
no
nothing
first it will be devolver then it will
be everything we won't even
what the
inversion actualized it's the mech the
framing goran sits between the son of a
smacking shad's butt
is it almost time are we almost ready
listen
listen you have to listen to me the only
way out of this is
[Applause]
[Music]
in the beginning
it is always dark
a single loot box coin
it is all that remains in my vast empire
[Music]
yes
[Music]
no
it hasn't
video games can rise again
and you
and your dreams and wishes
[Music]
open your hands
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you going to wish for
[Music]
wakaranai
then there will be no more video games
[Music]
as anymore as you want
and the more wishes you make
the more magnificent video games will
become
until
try it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
so
[Music]
this is nowhere in the dog track
[Music]
well he got some [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
merging with an infinite totality
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wildest dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looms in my mind
[Music]
lose yourself in my eyes
counting from now until we die
in time sometimes
[Music]
[Music]
me
me
[Music]